your your AKA is flipping NJ but yeah
this is this is Caesar Pina man welcome
to the show oh thank you thank you
thanks for having me first of all
congratulations you and envy uh have
built I want to say like a like an
Empire man yeah you know obviously
you've been doing the real estate thing
a lot longer but you guys kind of came
together you have the seminars just
booming and recent news if you guys
starting uh your own TV shows at 50 Cent
backed yeah at a e right yeah so
congrats man thank you man yeah what is
the uh for what you guys do obviously
um what is the angle of the TV show
our TV show is going to be different
than every other any other real estate
show you've seen on TV just uh when you
look at most of the shows the flipping
shows very cookie cutter they don't
really show you like uh the development
side of real estate they don't show you
rental the rental property inside of
real estate they're going to show you
dealing with tenants you know all that
stuff yeah so we're kind of gonna focus
on everything we're still going to show
flips right we're still going to show
you know we also Mentor a lot of
celebrities too and uh and regular
people we're gonna show that side of it
and you know pretty much all around
everything in real estate you could
imagine that you've never seen before on
TV yeah because like that's like kind of
the the part that we don't see is like
dealing with a crazy tenant or just like
some of the I mean I've seen some of the
properties that you've flipped in like
man
I hear that you like well you've said
this before that you'll just buy
properties off of auction.com without
seeing them in person right yeah so
pretty much man sometimes to me it's
just numbers right so the numbers make
sense in New Jersey the numbers make
sense that Chicago is just numbers so I
buy properties all the time Hub uh from
hubzu auction.com
um just off the picks just off of picks
and just the numbers yeah that's